bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtone en direct
je m'appelle l'admr y vivent aujourd'hui
autour de la table plusieurs invités des
femmes parce que c'est un sujet qui
concerne les femmes
nous allons parler des nouvelles
dispositions à la loi est roi alors la
loi et ce trois pour certains ça veut
dire quelque chose pour d'autres non on
va tout vous expliquer ça avec nos
invités et notre chroniqueuse habituel
isabelle picard bonjour ou miku est
également une invitée qui arrive
d'odanak florence bénédicte bonjour
alors florence vous êtes une élue en
fait à odanak vous êtes une conseillère
n'est ce pas oui voilà et puis vous
travaillez également à représenter les
femmes des femmes autochtones section
locale
oui exactement nous attendons une
troisième invité c'est viviane michel la
présidente de femmes autochtones du
québec elle est en route alors elle va
arriver là incessamment sous peu
et puis nous avons à ottawa cynthia smit
qui va témoigner de de ce que cause
comme désagrément la loi et ce trois ans
fait de la loi sur les indiens dans
cette vie
cynthia bonjour vous nous entendez bien
vous ne voyez bien tout va bien
excellent super alors nous allons
revenir à vous dans quelques instants
mais d'abord d'abord on va expliquer que
depuis le 15 août 2019
tous les descendants qui sont nés avant
le 17 avril 1985 de faim parce que c'est
bien important de le préciser la de
femmes qui ont perdu leur statut
d'indien ou ico qui ont été radiés des
listes de bandes en raison de leur
mariage avec un homme non autochtone
donc un homme sans statut auront droit
de s'inscrire au registre des indiens et
ça c'est une décision qui va mettre à
niveau là tous les descendants de sexe
masculin entre autres qui n'ont jamais
perdu leur statut alors c'est ça sera
une avancée pour les femmes mais donc
pour expliquer en détail pour bien
comprendre ce qui est arrivé aux femmes
depuis la création de la loi sur les
indiens
1 isabelle deux alliés nous en faire
l'historique oui oui parce que c'est pas
un sujet qui fasse un exemple et je le
fais des fois dans mon dos me cours à
l'université j'ai besoin de tableau
vraiment expliquer avec des graphiques
oui alors j'ai choisi de vous parler de
quelques femmes ou même un homme à la
fin qui ont marqué disons les luttes sur
les femmes autochtones et je vais
commencer par marie tooth axe relais qui
est un nez sur le territoire mohawk de
kahnawake en 1911
donc elle elle va s'installer à l'âge de
18 ans à brooklyn dans une petite
communauté mohawk on va appeler le petit
coq nawab puisqu'il y avait plusieurs
travailleurs de l'acier et du fer ils
provenaient d'enquêté maroc et donc
qu'ils provenaient du québec il y en a
encore beaucoup aujourd'hui nos corps et
queen effectue donc elle elle va
rencontrer un électricien d'origine
irlandaise et elle veut se marier et
avoir deux enfants
et là c'est en 1966 qu'elle va commencer
à défendre les droits des femmes
autochtones et ce qui se passe c'est
qu'un soir son amie mme horrocks va
décéder dans ses bras d'une crise
cardiaque lors d'une soirée chez eux
conjoint non une amie à venir oui oui
oui
et donc elle mérite au hac seul il faut
croire que c'est le stress qui ont
contribué finalement à la mort de son
ami puisqu'elles sont amies se battait
contre le conseil de bande qui refusait
depuis plusieurs plusieurs fois en fait
ces droits de propriété sur sa
communauté de gameblog est plus qu elle
aussi avait perdu ses droits en mariant
un an de nuit c'est ça alors mais oui
tout absolue va organiser une série de
campagnes pour faire connaître cette loi
discriminatoire et les abus qui peuvent
s'ensuivre pour les femmes autochtones
en 1967 elle va se joindre au mouvement
indian wait for indian au mobile
c'est un groupe de défense qui ont pour
mission de résister au colonialisme
sexuelle en fer est donc cette même
année il y as au canada des audiences de
la commission royale d'enquêté sur la
situation des femmes et donc le
mouvement indian oil india murinvest y
faire entendre
la commission va d'ailleurs recommandé
dans son rapport que la loi sur les
indiens soient modifiées afin que toute
femme et d'y en se mariant
non indiens finalement plus un conserver
son statut et le transmettre à ses
enfants
mais le canada va s'en laver les mains
donc ironie du sort 18 mois plus tard
mais oui tout accès au lait devient
veuve et là elle même ne peut plus
revenir dans sa communauté d'origine
puisque les chefs s'oppose aux accents
retourner à son retour ainsi que eller
elle a perdu son statut elle a perdu
absolument et il ya aussi la fraternité
nationale des indiens qui est un peu
l'ancêtre de l'assemblée des premières
nations qui aussi vont se montrer peu
enclin à changer les choses pour les
femmes un homme donne et son peut en
être surpris en 1975 mais 8 ou actionner
participe avec 60 autres femmes
autochtones de kahnawake à la conférence
de l'année internationale de la femme à
mexico et pendant cette conférence
elle veut recevoir un appel téléphonique
qui va informer que son conseil de bande
a envoyé à toutes les femmes qui
participent à cet événement un pré avis
d'expulsion de leurs communautés en leur
absence alors mairie va profiter du
momentum et de l'écho médiatique de
l'événement auquel elle participe pour
lever le voile sur la discrimination
raciale et sexuelle dont les femmes
autochtones sont victimes et la
couverture médiatique va être tellement
important que le conseil de bande de
kahnawake va changer élevé cet avis
d'exécution là donc c'est vraiment une
pionnière qui vaut jeter la lumière sur
la discrimination dans la loi sur les
indiens et ses effets à l'égard des
femmes oui mais elle n'a pas été la
seule elle n'est pas la seule
et là j'ai envie de vous parler de
jeannette viviane corbières dont qui
naît en 1942 de parents obligent hibou
et sur l'île manitoulin dans le nord de
l'ontario
adulte elle elle déménage à toronto et
là elle va s'engager comme travailleuse
sociale elle va travailler auprès des
jeunes et des canadiennes ceinture et en
1965 elle va être désigné princesse
indienne du canada et la sociologie
sujet je savais même pas que ça existait
pour vrai on en parlera dans une autre
émission mais ça va faire un sort
qu'elle veut devenir populaire donc ça
va accroître sa visibilité dans les
médias et donc ça va être important pour
la suite des choses
en 1960
jeannette corbiere i pod épouse david
clavel qui est un homme non autochtone
originaire de toronto et elle vaut
perdre ses droits et son statut
donc là elle va lancer une action en
justice contre le gouvernement fédéral
sur la base de la violation de la
déclaration canadienne des droits de
1960 la sphère la vesle arrive en même
temps ou la faire courber norbert arrive
en même temps qu'une qu'une cause
connexes la sphère bédard qui met en jeu
even bédard qui elle aussi a perdu son
statut d'indien dans les mêmes
circonstances
donc les deux femmes rencontrent encore
une fois une bonne résistance de la part
des autochtones eux mêmes
on parle encore de la fraternité
nationale des indiens qui les autres
étaient à l'époque d'anti indienne est
néanmoins les demanderesses vont quand
même continué le calvaire ont quand même
eu donc en berne
parce que c'est un organisme qui étaient
là pour la défendre mais bien la
restructuration oui oui et de tous les
autochtones oui alors madame corbières
re va aller en première instance en fait
la demande de madame corbières va être
rejetée elle veut se rendre en appel
elles vont remporter l'appel en 1971
toutefois en 1973 la cour suprême du
canada va venir infirmé cette décision
alors ces batailles même si elles ont
été perdus le même chose pour madame
bédard vont donner du courage à
plusieurs femmes autochtones et là c'est
le cas de la sénatrice que vous
connaissez peut-être sandra loveless qui
à l'époque était donc on est dans les
années 80 c'est une jeune avocate
malécites et elle elle veut se rendre
jusqu'à l'onu pour plaider sa cause sur
ce même en jeu alors il s'est dit si je
peux pas le faire examiner regrette pays
et aller ailleurs je pensais d'abord oui
les zones ans dont on est en national où
cela va fonctionner plus qu'en 1981 la
commission des droits de l'homme va
statuer que les dispositions
sexospécifique de la loi sur les indiens
en matière de statut vont compte revenir
au pacte international relatif aux
droits civils et politiques de l'ongle
le canada n'aura d'autre choix que de
modifier la loi sur les indiens par la
fameuse loi c 31 donc c'est important
qu'on connaît
plusieurs modifications donc la première
une loi qui est effective en 1985 et
donc la loi c'est 31 ce que ça fait
c'est que ça va permettre à toutes les
femmes qui ont perdu leur statut en
mariant une onde un non autochtone de
retrouver leur statut mais ça ne se
touchent pas aux générations à venir ça
donc les seuls trucs
oui alors sharon mais kaiser et l'heure
est elle c'est une autochtone de la
colombie-britannique qui elle aussi
avait marqué un non autochtone avant
1985 et donc elle a perdu ses droits
en 1985 elle est étudiante en droit et
la loi c'est 31 entre en fonction et là
elle demande au gouvernement son statut
pourrait elle de même que pour son fils
oui on lui donne à elle mais on ne lui
donne pas à son fils oui alors elle dit
bon bleus il ya encore une inégalité là
ça n'est pas normal parce que son frère
qui lui aussi a marié une non autochtone
lui a le droit de transmettre son statut
assez en valeur
donc elle va plaider à l'onu elle va
aussi intenter une plainte contre le
canada en 1989
une plainte qui va se rendre jusqu'en
cour suprême et ça va prendre sept ans
dans son cas avant que ce ne soit
entendu quelle patience vraiment c'est
incroyable
heureusement on va lui donner raison ce
qui va amener la loi c-3 donc en 2010 si
je me trompe pas ce qui va faire en
sorte que les enfants de femmes qui ont
retrouvé leur statut poste 1985 peuvent
aussi leur transe les transmettre à
leurs enfants ni encore des inégalités
qu'en est il des petits zambiens sur
voilà alors ce qui m'amène à la s3 le
sujet d'aujourd'hui je sais que c'est
une longue chronique mais tant pis aller
faire porte c'était très important pour
lui de prendre vraiment les tenants et
les aboutissants et pourquoi on en est
rendu là où la bonne humeur est donc la
sphère des chenaux donc le demandeur
stéphane c'est un jeunot c'est un homme
oui si oui il est il vient d'odanak donc
un abénakis d'odanak
et il a des enfants nés entre 2002 et
2007 et en termes de statut il est un
peu l'équivalent du fisc de sharon mais
kaiser vous savez celui qui ont retrouvé
selon sal souscrite à la c3 oui donc
stéphane des chenaux obtient un statut
de 6,2 parce que leur soit aussi il faut
savoir que des status histoires et des
statuts cse
sont les alinéas oui ça sent les allumés
a donc si ça c'est légalement deux par
un autochtone légalement je dis bien et
6 2 6 1 par an non autochtone avec un
parent autochtone en fait une wii
tant que c'est l'âme c'est la mer mais
les choses vont les choses vont un peu
changé donc stéphane ne peut pas
transmettre son statut à ses enfants
puisque c'était sa grand mère oui qui
était autochtones et non pas son
grand-père s'inviter son grand père il
aurait pu le faire
voilà alors c'est lol et il va se rendre
bien sûr en cours et le 3 ou 2015 la
cour supérieure du québec va invalider
les alinéas 6,1 à c et f et le
paragraphe 6 2 de la loi sur les indiens
et la cour va juger qu'il porte atteinte
au droit à l'égalité tel que garanti par
l'article 15 de la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés est donc en octobre
2016 le gouvernement fédéral va
introduire le projet de loi est roi il
va y avoir une série de consultations et
l'on verra avec nos invités du oui est
vraiment nécessaire exact ce qu'ils vont
mener à l'adoption de la s3 le 15 août
dernier
voilà et donc la loi la loi est roi a
reçu la sanction en fait le projet doit
reçu la sanction royale au mois d'août
donc maintenant elle est en vigueur et
les temps wild card et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis
vous allez pouvoir nous dire florence
bénédicte à odanak est ce qui s'est
passé depuis pour les femmes qui
désirent retrouver leur statut
vous aimez c'est oui quelques oeufs mais
ça s'est rapidement les gens comme son
portrait très au courant ça rentre
tranquillement penseurs assister à une
grande vague de demain wii 2 pour
établir les statuts tout ça mais non ça
va ça va tranquillement c'est c'est gras
duel puis il nourrit pas grâce à remplir
comment ça fonctionne
ils doivent remplir des formulaires ce
sont des formulaires aussi qu'ils
doivent remplissez des fois c'est quand
même complexe ou 6 puis ça prince après
tout un puits d'accord alors on va se
tourner tout de suite vers notre invité
cynthia smit elle est à ottawa
cynthia vous vous faites partie de cette
génération qui a perdu son statut
d'indien
est-ce que vous même voulu vous l'avez
en fait et ce sont vos enfants qu'ils ne
l'auront pas expliqué nous dans
quelqu'un vous vous trouvez quelqu'un
qui n'a rien d'une école en chine à
pékin et d'or
bonjour tout le monde donc
quand je disais je me présente je
m'appelle m et je suis un jeune abbé qu
est la raison pour laquelle nous
présente comme un mish nabé quoi c'est
que comme vous l'avez vous même souligné
légalement au moment où on se parle le
gouvernement ne me reconnaît pas comme
une indienne statuer au sens de la loi
portant
je me considère bel et bien en chine a
beaucoup et je prends cette
responsabilité l'on a fait de
m'identifier
par respect pour mes ancêtres et aussi
comme une responsabilité que je sens que
je porte pour les générations futures
mon conjoint quant à lui et il est né
lizio attikameks et il est lui statut et
donc comme isabelle expliqué un peu plus
tôt il ya des catégories donc si cet
institut est de son côté en fait quand
ces rencontres et un moment donné ou un
autre moi j'ai pris la responsabilité de
lui parler de ma situation parce que y'a
pas tout le monde qui est un au courant
de ce que c'est qu'il ya des catégories
avec la loi sur les indiens et aussi des
impacts que ça peut avoir
donc moi je lui masse ionique justement
j'étais pas statué et les faits les
répercussions que cela pouvait avoir sur
à nos enfants et notre famille parce
qu'on on voulait former une famille
ensemble est-ce qu'ils connaissaient la
réalité lui il savait pas en fait qui
est qu'il y avait des catégories ça veut
même pas c'est lui il était 6 1 6 2 donc
ça c'est quelque chose de ce qui est
important pour moi de mentionner parce
que c'est comme comme florence a
mentionné c'est tellement complexe
puisque souvent dans nos communautés on
n'est pas au courant puis on sait même
pas quel point ça nous impact puisque ça
veut dire dans nos propres réalités
donc moi quand je lui laissais saint
usuge appelé au gouvernement fait pour
que le ministère l'informent que qu'il
était c'est ça qui est donc nos enfants
pouvait statuer
mais au niveau 6 2 et donc l'impact que
cela a sur nos enfants ces lieux communs
806 du dépendamment bas actuellement
dépendamment de la personne avait qu'ils
auront des enfants plus tard s'ils ont
des enfants leurs enfants seront soit
reconnue légalement ou faux départ
oui alors ça va dépendre si vos enfants
marie vous avez des garçons ou des
filles deux filles oui c'est important
de préciser comme vous avez deux filles
si vos filles marie des non autochtones
elles perdront leur statut d'indien
exacte avec la nouvelle loi ça la change
et agde demain
alors où est ce que ça va avoir un
impact ça allait pas conscience que nous
nos filles elles sont elles sont
actuellement 6 2 donc si nous ont fait
un projet ensemble pour retourner dans
la communauté avoir une maison dans la
communauté
donc actuellement comment cela
fonctionne c'est que comme c'est mon
conjoint qui est un numéro de membre
dans la communauté lui pour repasser la
la maison aux enfants n'ont qu'à nos
filles comme elle son statut mais si les
deux filles par exemple ont des enfants
avec quelqu'un qui est post a tué nos
petits enfants pourront pas habiter dans
la communauté parce que la loi sur les
indiens interdite maintenant si si par
exemple votre conjoint s'il arrive quoi
que ce soit votre conjoint vous même
puisque vous n'êtes pas encore statué
allez-vous quand même pouvoir vivre dans
la communauté ben c'est on veut parler
en termes de vivre dans la communauté où
on est choyé parce que notre communauté
dans le fond s'est même attaché mon
match et c'était une communauté qui est
très accueillante
donc les gens
ils m'accueillent puis ils savent que je
suis un chien ben quoi je suis pas né à
wemotaci ou qui a mes parents viennent
pas de wemotaci directement mais donc
ils vont accepter que j'étais je fasse
partie de la communauté comme ils font
en ce moment mais légalement au sens de
la loi
je pourrais pas faire de demande pour
avoir une maison donc habiter dans la
communauté ça c'est pas quelque chose
que je pourrais donc puis comme effet en
ce moment sont mineurs pour répondre à
votre question s'il arrivait quelque
chose dans mon conjoint et moi je
pourrais pas je serai comme prisa
faudrait qu'ils aiment ma belle famille
n'en font s'ils acceptent que je reste
là puis j'habite a vécu ce c'est ce
moyen que jours avant de pouvoir rester
dans la communauté avec ma famille mais
là maintenant avec les modifications au
projet de loi est roi vous allez pouvoir
demander de recevoir le statut d'
indienne ben c'est ce à quoi on va faire
c'est quelque chose qui va pouvoir se
faire
moi ma question c'est resté beaucoup au
niveau de l'admissibilité donc comme il
ya été question un peu plus tôt c'est
beaucoup de papier c'est c'est un
processus qui est pas aléatoire mais
c'est que la loi est tellement difficile
à comprendre
il ya tellement d'aline et il ya
tellement complexité de temps il ya
aussi une certaine présomption quand on
parle de parentalité nom des clarisses
qui est le commandant notre famille
également donc c'est c'est pas certain à
100% on peut pas être certains à 100%
qu'on veut recevoir notre statut ou pas
donc ça aussi c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles moi je vais de l'avant au
niveau 2 de la fierté puis c'est le
message que j'aimerais partager
aujourd'hui que la loi sur les indiens
c'est un système colonial qui était mis
sur pied dans un objectif d'assimiler et
d'éteindre tous les tous les indiens
tous les autochtones au canada
donc moi en tant que nom statuer au sens
de la loi
le message que je porte c'est que c'est
pas le gouvernement qui va me dire qui
je suis qui je ne suis pas en paca nice
n'a bent en caniche nain beckwith c'est
mes ancêtres c'est cette fierté là que
je porte en
et je le fais pour les générations
futures vraiment est-ce que vous avez de
l'espoir le sport pour être franche avec
vous j'en ai pour les générations
futures
mais je la vois dans la restauration de
nos propres ordre juridique donc dans la
restauration de nos propres systèmes
comment nous on s'identifie en tant que
jeune abbé en tant que nous lisions
attikameks en temps qui nous comment
est-ce que nos propres systèmes en
définit qui est nos propres qui sont nos
propres citoyens
alors on a reçu notre notre dernière
invitée elle a couru oui bonjour vous
bien michel est ce qu'on entend bien
viviane louis hess commentant oui
excellent en train de faire ça et vous
courrez dit dès aujourd'hui vous étiez
un colosse matin oui on était sur le
colloque sur la résistance des femmes
autochtones et les gens posent des
questions et non je regarde la vente
leur avance le trafic est évidemment
suivre on va laver personne ne vous a
posé de questions sur les nouvelles
dispositions projet de loi et ce trois
non non c'est pas parce que c'est quand
même sujet qui est un homme inconnu
encore oui c'est ceux qui ne sont pas
concernés directement oui où exactement
mais par contre vous afin de autochtones
du québec vous le connaissez le sujet
parce que vous le vous y aide sur ce
qu'alain depuis très longtemps avant
même vous votre arrivée comme président
un depuis les débuts de femmes
autochtones du québec
et voilà on peut reculer de bien avant
1974 où des femmes en étaient
discriminés ont perdu leur statut et une
belle bataille à s'est mis sur pied une
bataille qui n'est pas terminée parce
qu'il ya encore tellement d'enjeux a
réglé malgré ce qui vient d'être d'être
décidée là il ya encore beaucoup de
choses qui doivent être discutées on
l'entend avec ce que nous disent il
tient en ce moment d'ailleurs
oui juste faire un petit un rappel avec
cynthia j'ai travaillé avec cynthia
smith qui a été mon analyse juridique
politique et à femmes autochtones du
québec
on travaille beaucoup la discrimination
dénoncer la discrimination faite aux
femmes etc et quand qu'on a engagés
cynthia quête anishnabe ok mais qui est
pas reconnu au sens de la loi
là je me suis dit mais maicon
on est en train quand même nous mêmes en
tant qu'organisation d'exercer des
formes discriminatoire ça m'a fait
vraiment travaillé longtemps
émotionnellement parce que je fais très
attention de ne pas discriminer une
lumière se fait très attention de ne pas
faire du racisme non plus mais parfois
dans les organisations comme autochtones
du québec
on y est on est confronté avec ses
réalités là c'est une question de deux
époux de taxes ou les c'était important
pour moi justement de le mentionner avec
cynthia que ça m'a fait travailler moi
en tant que président d'une organisation
qui travaille contre la discrimination
alors revenons à la ce projet de loi est
roi vous avez été approché fins
autochtones du québec on vous a demandé
votre avis sur sur sur les différentes
dispositions sur lesquelles on
travaillait est ce que est ce que vous
êtes en accord avec tout ce qui a été
décidé qu'est ce qu'il manque
il manque encore des choses parce que
évidemment oui leur maintenance avec bel
et bien inscrit que c'est vraiment une
lois qui discriminent les femmes elles
vont être enlevées de la loi sur les
indiens évidemment mais en même temps il
ya aussi le côté nous affament
autochtone qu'on a toujours des preuves
dénoncer c'est la paternité non déclarés
qui nous est imposé
ça il reste encore une bataille puis
depuis le début de la consultation qui a
eu sur la loi et ce trois qu'on a dit
pourquoi est ce que nous en tant que
femme autochtone
on nous impose ce genre de de
réglementation puis encore les forme
d'assimilation qui sont encore visés
écoute une québécoise qui est un enfant
qui est pas de déclaration
de paternité ça aucun impact d'enfants
vont être québécois canadien mais
pourquoi est ce que nous en tant que
femme autochtone
on nous impose sa etc inquiète pas de
déclaration de paternité automatiquement
dans la loi sur des terrains deviennent
le gouvernement dit que cet enfant là
est né d'un père canadien québécois
canadien vous parlez de femmes qui ont
le statut et voilà mais je parle de
femmes qui ont des statuts et salades et
un paquet de plus en plus la réalité des
femmes autochtones maintenant de plus en
plus on devient mère à 12 ans 13 ans 14
ans dans l'intérieur des communautés et
il ya cette méconnaissance encore à
l'intérieur des communautés on doit
travailler la sensibilisation
quand ma fille était enceinte mois de
son bébé on est rendu là juste pour
montrer où est ce que ça nous amène
j'étais demande à ton conjoint d'écrire
une lettre comme quoi et reconnaît le
père de son enfant qui est dans ton
quand je vois ça va loin
bil'in l'asie mais pourquoi est là je
lui explique tout le système qui peut
avoir des impacts et paoua on sait
jamais quand est ce que le partenaire
peut partir on sait jamais quand est-ce
que de partenaires peut mourir aussi
donc nous ça nous emmène à des des
conséquences de ce genre et à faire des
précautions de ce sont alors ses
amendements là c'est changement là ont
quand même des impacts énormes et on le
voit ça risque de diviser aussi juste
les diverses nations les diverses
communautés les enjeux sont différents
les uns pour les autres on va parler du
cas d'odanak c'est une bonne nouvelle
oui mais si je peux ajouter dans le code
et cynthia est justement l'impact avec
les gens qu'ils retrouvent leur statut
ça fait beaucoup de monde et tout ça et
puis nous on a l'oeil et de personnes
oui et nous depuis 2002 en un code de
citoyenneté qui définit kyi peut faire
partie de la bande et je crois que dans
le futur proche les autres communautés
devront en avoir un je sais que quelques
quelques autres en ont déjà
mais c'est sûr qu'avec tous les
changements comme
macgyver la s3 tout ça va falloir
rouvrir notre code de citoyenneté et
l'ajuster avec une vertu elle cite entre
autres j'ai pas tout mais en trente nous
pour pouvoir prétendre être à la bande
appartenir à la bande des abénakis il
faut que ton grand-père et intègre
apparaît a été inscrit au registre des
indiens que ce soit ton grand-père de ta
grand mère dont le grand père ou la
grand mare aux origines syndic mais ça
va changer parce que on vient d'avoir un
communiqué qui abolit la date de 1951
donc il faut se réajuster et ça change
beaucoup de choses aussi falloir que les
conseils de mende se dote de code des
citoyennetés pour être capable de tout
gérer sont alors à odanak c'est combien
de personnes pourraient se prévaloir du
statut de membre d'odanak je peux pas
vous le dire j'en ai aucune idée
je sais que ça commence à rentrer
tranquillement on a vu une centaine
centaine donc on pense qu'ils peuvent
mais on on attend les demandes et où
l'eau mais vous pouvez en accueillir
combien parce qu'en fait elle est là la
réalité aussi là d'un défi aussi mis un
enjeu important parmi eux on sait que
dans les quarante trois communautés au
québec toutes les communautés sont en
mode survivance économique
oui mais l'accès au logement elle est
vraiment très
très restreinte l'éducation la santé et
ça et même moi moi pour avoir marché
pour la loire c'est pour la
réinscription des vermines autochtone
qui étaient en attente d'être inscrits
on n'a pas été soutenu par par nos
leaders politiques et je peux comprendre
pourquoi parce que justement il ya cette
partie de la survivance économique et
comment ils vont réintégrer ces gens là
et c'est la même chose avec la doua ses
31 qui a eu les femmes qui ont été
réinscrit est ce qu'on les fait rentrer
ou non à l'intérieur et il ya aussi chez
nous partout un peu partout dans ce
délai les premières nations ont exercé
ces mêmes formes coloniale s'est même
pas rationnel en dix ans ben de marier
un humble en tête une blanche maintenant
c'est c'est vraiment l'héritage de la
loi qui est vraiment coloniale encore et
qu'on exerce moi je dis toujours on
l'exercé inconsciemment aussi parfois
absolument combi combien une famille
l'udc sont venus dans mon cours de
gouvernance que fin fako mise sur pied
et qu'il n'était pas au courant des 6 5
et 6 2 et c'est la discrimination de
commencer à fonctionner et le
colonialisme à l'intérieur des conseils
de bonne combine une chaîne qui sont pas
au courant c'est ça c'est ça
et en même temps les codes
d'appartenance on parle de code de
citoyens comme d'appartenance les
communautés présentement même si les
20000 ont été inscrits lindois ses 31
des femmes qui ont retrouvé leur statut
et maintenant ça va être vraiment
cette loi la loi est complètement
rétabli les gens les communautés ne sont
même pas préparé à ça encore écoutez
nous on à sortir communiqué de presse
nous c'est le bonheur total pour la
situation des femmes là on ya des femmes
qui se sont battues l'an ont dit oui la
discrimination faite aux femmes et voilà
on gagne une grande bataille si quelque
chose c'est des années que les langues
se sont battus et on va fêter bientôt on
va fêter lyon va prendre le 26 septembre
fait ici à montréal on oublie les pentes
venez on va faire de l'histoire vous
raconter qu'est ce que cette loi a fait
sur la situation des femmes mais en même
temps je regarde un peu partout on
entend rien
pourquoi est ce qu'on entend pas
nouvelle pourquoi est ce que je vois pas
d communiqué mettons de l'assemblée des
premières nations québec-labrador sortir
bravo les femmes ont gagné une bataille
quoi pourquoi oui est ce que quelqu'un
peut répondre à la question pourquoi je
pourrais peut-être avancer une hypothèse
on est aussi meute on sait si c'est
vraiment super
le paye plus de discrimination pour les
femmes et tous et que les leurs
descendants aussi sauf c'est comme pas
vraiment le bon timing pour les
premières nations lors je prends mon
statut d'élu local mal comme ça que les
élus nos chefs
c'est ce qui plane aussi en même temps
c'est l'abolition du registre
c'est l'abolition des lois ces indiens
fait que j'ai fait beaucoup de choses en
même temps puis moi je dis encore c'est
important de se doter de code de
citoyenneté pour être capable de perdre
le contrôle non plus aussi puis on se le
cachera pas qu'il ya un impact financier
aussi parce que même en 85 même en 2010
même en 2010 est de mes cinq 2017
les fonds ne viennent pas avec les
lignes financer nouveau
des nouveaux les nouvelles personnes qui
retrouvent leur statut alors c'est on
sépare encore la reporter que déjà ce
moment va accueillir ces gens dont louis
pour préparer à ça un exemple concret
femmes autochtones du québec on avait
ont représenté les 10 nations sauf que
les m'a dit si tu n'étais pas présent
dans notre organisation
maintenant elles nous ont demandé une
place on est très très honoré on va
accueillir mais il ya une façon
d'accueillir ces gens là nous à notre
assemblée générale je le poke on hrw
refait les formes coloniale où les
formes raciales envers ces gens là oui
parce que moi je suis rentré dans une
salle et une québécoise qui aurait en
réalité je suis chez nous parce que
elles sont toutes elles ont des cheveux
bleus l oms l on s en blond les ont les
yeux bleus oui et je ne veux pas qu'on
reproduit ce qu'on a toujours vécu donc
on prépare nous l'entrée de cette nation
l'eau dans notre organisation
on va faire de l'histoire leur histoire
en raison pour faire comprendre et
cissokho devrait faire à l'intérieur des
nations pourquoi la situation des femmes
elle a été vraiment discriminante et
pourquoi nous on a été touchés même en
osant oui mais même à nos femmes parce
que les gens ne comprennent pas le sens
justement et l'impact que ça peut avoir
c'était très difficile de changer la
culture à l'inter mais à l'intérieur
même des communautés je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez mais thulliez que moi même
j'étais petit je prenais d'autobus des
indiens mais mon ami dont la mère avait
perdu son statut
embarqué dans une autre autobus c'est
très très discriminante y avait un
autobus pour les automobiles qui avaient
un autre tour les autres ceux qui
avaient pu accéder non qu'il a on est en
ânonnant c'était dans les années 70 en
france 110 début 80 et puis le soir tout
le monde était ensemble tout le monde
jouait ensemble tous au pire mais il
fallait changer ça ça a été ça n'a pas
été facile puis aujourd'hui femmes
autochtones c'est un mouvement
extraordinaire j'en fais partie puis
tellement fier aussi
et mais je me souviens d'un temps où on
parlait nous avons donné que les mains
les belles but 6 mai du des femmes
autochtones s'était ainsi cacher dans
les sous sols des maisons parce que les
hommes voyaient pas d'un bon oeil
il y avait des réunions secrètes dans
les sous sols on est très loin
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on classe bien à
nous pour mais dans votre communauté à
odanak donc on est les hommes sont sont
d'accord avec cette nouvelle réalité la
nascar retrouvent leur statut que des
femmes qui ont marié des non autochtones
retrouvent leur statut et inversement
pour les descendances pascallamour la
régie chez nous quand même bien des amis
là qu'il s'est séparé locke et diront
beaucoup aussi à vraiment valider la
discrimination béton par oui je pense
qu'à la base les chefs les hommes ne
sont pas contre mais le problème c'est
justement c'est le financement est ce
qu'on entend toujours rendu mais là on a
un même pot of gold podor oui j'ai
l'oeil
il faut le diviser mais là il restera
plus beaucoup pour chacun et même des
premières nations des communautés qui
ont dit on va faire un moratoire
chez nous chez les oies date mon dieu je
sais pas combien de gens qui vont
appliquer mais ça va être dans les
milliers donc ça va ça va quand même
énorme donc à gannat waziers on est pas
très heureux de cette décision là aussi
s'attendent à ce qu'ils aient des
milliers de personnes qui entraient la
hommes et femmes chez les élus on n'est
pas heureux et on veut essayer de se
battre contre les nouvelles dispositions
la jarre est amusé à répondre
directement et je souhaite réellement
cette émission que la chaîne sky soit
présent parce que elle a eu nos pays a
une opinion c'est assez clair ma session
lorsque ça aurait été bien d'apporter
aussi les pour et les cons faire
entendre au public chacun chacun des
nations ont leur propre façon intégrée
l'argent si je regarde un chef qui
m'avait parlé justement
quand les gens ont été ré inscrire dans
la loi ces trois mots dit ben nous on
veut faire l'exercice de réintégrer mais
c'est possible d'avoir une carte un
statut qu'il pense qu'on a des
privilèges on a nos potes privilèges et
c'était plus bon tu veut réintégrer en
tant que hinault bon ben viens viens
approche pour faire des cours de langue
beauvoir des aînés les cours de culture
c'était là sa façon de voir à réintégrer
ses propres gens et par la suite ça
aurait été la bataille est justement
administrative we sing we alesi soutien
oui justement je vous regarde et j'ai de
nouveau sous pression mais allez-y
répliqué c'est justin c'est avec vous
toute la junte à libérer je crois un
petit poucet avec ce qui est ce qui
vient d'être mentionné aussi en tant que
femme autochtone femmes c'est notre
responsabilité de faire l'éducation à
nos enfants nos familles ça fait partie
de nos rôles traditionnels mais aussi de
nos responsabilités et c'est quelque
chose il ya un mot qui est pour moi très
important responsabilités et que
j'aimerais prendre un moment pour le
saunier autant en tant que femme je suis
une jeune mère la commande a mentionné
tantôt j j'ai deux merveilleuses tue
tête de lumière qui m'ont choisie comme
maman nancy en tant que que comme c'est
mon conjoint lui il prend il travaille
pas essayer de rapporter les rôles
traditionnels aussi la gouvernance
traditionnel de l'ayrolle des hommes
aussi
parmi eux la
leurs nombreuses responsabilités c'est
de défendre et de protéger défendre et
protéger nos femmes aussi dans le camp
quant aux femmes vont de l'avant pour
pour une lutte comme par exemple comme
celle ci une femme ont été mises de côté
par des gens qui venaient de l'extérieur
système qui est venu d'extérieur et qui
a rechuté ce qui était sacré dans nos
nations disons les femmes les femmes
sont sacrées ont toujours été sacré et
je suis pas la seule à penser que au
moment où la loi sur les indiens été mis
sur pied c'est quelque chose qui était
connue du gouvernement donc c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles les femmes
précisément ont été touchées ainsi que
les enfants pour que les enfants c'est
l'avenir de nos nations
on peut le voir avec les pensionnats
pourquoi ce que c'est les enfants qui
ont été attaqués et donc la
responsabilité vraiment de se tenir
debout de nous supporter et et quand les
femmes sont violentées parce que c'est
une violence et une violence qui qui
même à d'autres violences dont on l'a vu
avec que ce soit le rapporteur spécial
des nations unies que ce soit dans la
décision qui a été rendue dans mes cas
vus aux nations unies que ce soit avec l
enquête nationale sur les femmes
disparues assassinées
toutes ont mentionné et j'en passe
toutes ont mentionné une corrélation
directe entre la discrimination que
vivent les femmes dans la loi sur les
indiens et la violence faite aux femmes
autant en milieu familial comme milieu
systémique donc encore une
discrimination et racisme systémique à
cause de cette loi là et je parlerai
aussi si je peux continuer le temps que
j'ai la part en actions au niveau de la
responsabilité la responsabilité
gouvernementale aussi il ya plusieurs
acteurs là qui sont impliqués
dans cette situation-là pied la
responsabilité gouvernementale le l'état
a retiré les femmes et les descendants
afin d'affaiblir d'enfants nos peuples
et nos nations dans des fins
assimilateur et colonial colonisatrice
et s'il était donc dans mon point de vue
ça en moi de sa responsabilité de
restaurer ce qu'il avait détruit donc 6
qui a tenté d'être fait depuis quelques
années et j'espère que ça va arrêter
mais si on garde ça c'est ma parenthèse
aussi le temps qu'on garde les
catégories ses 106 deuil va continuer d
abord discrimination mais ça aussi c'est
un autre sujet pour supporter aussi ce
que je viens de mentionner tout à leur
parentalité non déclarés soucier ça va
demeurer
mais la responsabilité qui a déjà été
mentionné par parme et mes soeurs qui
sont présentes sur le plateau mont royal
c'est la responsabilité financière il va
continuer d'y avoir discrimination face
aux gens qui reviennent dans les
communautés tant et aussi longtemps que
ces gens là sont perçus comme étant des
fléaux dit boulay on communauté ou
nation si c'est tout ce qu'on voit c'est
bien là on a plein de personnes qui
arrivent de 1 qui qui risque d'être
déconnecté d'une manière ou d'une autre
je le prends sur moi aussi c'est de ne
pas avoir pu grandir dans ma communauté
de pas pouvoir parler la langue de mes
sincères c'est quelque chose que je vis
une réalité que je me suis aussi une
réalité que vivent les jeunes qui ont
grandi dans ma communauté
donc ça c'est quelque chose aussi qu'on
partage en tant que communauté si on
veut être plus fort c'est de rapporter
cette fierté de dire qu'est ce que c'est
que pour toi que d'être anishnabe mois
qu'on me donne une carte de même dire si
atteint une carte et un indienne
maintenant qu'est-ce que ça va me faire
ça ça fait une reconnaissance ça ramène
un équilibre et à quelque part c'est
comme dire aux jambes et maintenant vous
avez pu l'excusent de me dire on peut
pas d'écouter soutien parce que t'as pas
de carte mais au-delà de ça est-ce que
je vais moins enseigné à mes enfants
plus enseignée non ça c'est pas cette
carte là qui volent
qui c'est ma responsabilité en tant que
femme en tant que caniche nabet quoi en
tant que maman d'enseigner sa mes
enfants et de partager ça sinon
responsabilités et on à ses
responsabilités selon moi en tant que
nation d'accueillir ces gens qui
viennent et de mettre sur pied des
systèmes comment les accueils de faire
attention comme viviana dit tout à
l'heure au sit in au code des
citoyennetés nos codes d'appartenance de
fer intention d' pas perpétuer cette
discrimination et le racisme parce que
c'est difficile d'enlever le toutes ces
années de colonisation
c'est facile de dire de se limiter à
ossun parce que c'est ça que la loi
parle mais chez les hindous b par
exemple n'est pas une niche avec part ça
ternit chanabé parce que tu fais partie
de la communauté parce que tu prends tes
responsabilités parce que tu parle la
langue parce que tu connais les
traditions comme tout le monde c'est ça
que d'être indochine ambert huawei
conversation qu'on pourrait continuer
encore longtemps hélas le temps file de
très rapidement pour terminer parce
qu'on l'entende y aussi pendant la
conversation beaucoup d'autochtones et
beaucoup de encore plus de non
autochtone ne ne connaissent pas les
implications donc de la loi sur les
indiens et de ce projet de loi est roi
où est ce qu'ils peuvent se renseigner
comment est ce qu ils peuvent se
renseigner super ya quand même un numéro
de téléphone où est ce que des gens
peuvent vérifier parce que oui oui c'est
avec canada canada.ca relation couronne
autochtones à ferdinand et le numéro de
téléphone dont je suis la publicité pour
le
c'était 800 5 6 7 85 04 peau savoir si
les gens sont admissibles à 805 6 5 5 7
96 24 ore excusez-moi 96 04 96 09 10 04
et c'est là qu'ils vont avoir toute
l'information les renseignements dont
ils parlent
les questions peuvent être posées
directement cet appel d'accord voilà
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir été là
aujourd'hui pour pour discuter de ces
enjeux qui sont cruciaux pour les femmes
merci d'avoir été là cynthia smit à
ottawa merci pour votre témoignage et
bonne chance pour la suite on cote
viviane michel merci d'avoir été
présente je sais que vous avez un
horaire surchargé de premier ministre
manger un big hogan pour fondement des
femmes anishnabe d'accord ben écoutez je
vous laisse aller merci d'avoir été
présente
vous allez rentrer à odanak florence
bénédicte merci beaucoup pour leur
présence et puis isabelle picard on se
retrouve très bientôt merci encore une
fois merci et merci nous avons donné
toutes ses explications vraiment mettre
la table ça nous a éclairci un gros
nuage qui était presque incompréhensible
au départ de s'effacer maintenant
prendre absolument alors merci beaucoup
et merci à vous d'avoir été présent
encore une fois si vous avez des
questions des commentaires aller sur la
page facebook ou encore sur la page de
l'émission d' espace autochtone allait
poser vos questions vos commentaires vos
incompréhension et bien sûr nous allons
content que possible d'y répondre
voilà merci à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]